Tired of everyone telling you that social
media is making you sad?
Now science says its might actually make you
less stressed!
[DNews Open]
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Some people say technology is taking over
our lives.
Over half of those online use two or more
social networks.
Some worry this is making us more isolated
and more stressed out as we try to keep up
with the joneses.
Recent study from the Pew Research Center
suggests otherwise.
Social media can make us feel a little lonely,
we have a constant stream of other people’s
business and it’s too easy to keep comparing
ourselves to them.
People carefully craft their online personas
and some people get stressed out from the
comparison.
But it’s like comparing your outtakes to
everyone elses highlights.
And then there’s keeping up with yourself,
just like other people try to position themselves
in a good light, you can get too wrapped up
in doing the same.
Trying to show only your best angle, your
wittiest statuses and your best days at work
and home.
And there’s the fact you're keeping up with
other’s stress.
Using social media makes you more likely to
be aware of the stress going on in the lives
of your family and friends.
This could make you your stress levels rise
as well.
This is what researchers call “The Cost
of Caring.”
Yet there’s a flipside to all of that.
Being better connected through technology
means well, you’re better connected.
Previous studies show that active social media
users, have more close friends, feel more
supported, are more trusting, and even more
politically active than their disconnected
or less connected peers.
For this study, participants in the survey
were asked about their social media use, what
websites they use and how they use them.
They found the link between social media and
stress is pretty indirect.
But it did show that women seemed to benefit
more than men from being better connected,
even though women report being more stressed
overall.
On a Perceived Stress Scale, women reported
overall stress levels 7% higher than men.
But with all the keeping up with the Joneses
stuff, how is this possible?
How does social media reduce stress?
Well it’s a few things.
Women might be burdened with “maintaining
household relationships” and typically,
they tend to share their emotional experiences
more than men.
Social media allows for a low-demand easily
accessible way to share.
It’s more efficient and saves time.
Also, there’s kind of a schadenfreude effect
here.
Well the researchers say it’s a little nicer
than that, they call it “the joy of missing
out.”
For some women who are more aware of stressful
events in the people who aren’t so close
to them, their level of stress was lower by
6%.
I guess putting your stress into context and
realizing you don’t have it as bad as that
other guy is kind of a relief.
And using these technologies more frequently
can be key to being less stressed.
On average those women who send pictures through
their phones, send and receive around 25 emails
a day and who more frequently use twitter,
have 21% less stress than their peers who
don’t use any of these.
And these benefits aren’t entirely just
for women.
Social media users of both genders report
higher feelings of social support and are
more aware of the resources available in their
network.
And like anything, how you use it matters.
So rather than just scrolling facebook and
browsing twitter, interacting with PEOPLE
on these sites leads to a better feeling.
Just like in days of old, communicating, sharing
and supporting make us feel better and feel
less stressed, we just have a new way of doing
it.
For more information on this study and others
like it check out the links in the description,
and check out THIS video, Tara will tell you
the reason some people in your facebook feed
are prone to oversharing.
We all know that one guy.
What do you think?
do you feel close to people with texting and
social media? or does it make you feel lonely?
let us know in the comments below!